okay I just have to say something if you
have lip filler Botox
fake lashes fake hair nails done you're
gonna come on and tell me how the cost
of living is too high and your living
paycheck to paycheck I don't want to
hear it you don't have to do that now I
know a lot of women see these as
Necessities not a necessity I know this
is crazy but you can't tell me how you
can't afford if I could see your
forehead not moving when you smile
because you clearly have botox oh that's
that place to like two grand a month now
these men have to come in and maintain
you you will get no sympathy no sympathy
from me if you have all that done thank
you that is my daily rant